The daughter gets a anxiety, especially around her cycle. What could be the cause?
Well, any type of mood issues with your children, and obviously,
or other cycles, your kids must be 13, 14, 15 years old. You certainly think
any type of issues around the person's cycle, you think, or modal issues. The most common
hormonal issues in young adults are just a decreased function in a adrenal gland,
many times these kids are fairly stressed with school and the pressures of school
decreased function, but to a cherry gland, just getting them on some adaptogens is the number one
thing to look at. Adaptogenic herbs are called adaptogens because they help you adapt to your
environment, and they do so, they help balance your thyroid and your pituitary and your adrenal glands,
and those are the glands that control, you know, progesterone and estrogen output,
and can help with any issues with your cycles. That would be the first thing to start.
Obviously, getting tested, there's some adrenal stress tests out there. There's hormone
Dutch tests that also test the adrenal glands and look at that. Also, genetic issues can be an issue
with that. I mentioned earlier that a person that has or defects in their genetic pathways called
the biopterant pathways can be more prone to imbalances in neurotransmitters, and then certain dietary
things can cause it in flux, can push that pathway too hard, and cause excess or deficiencies in
dopamine or serotonin, or other neurotransmitters as well, and you ought to look at that.
All sorts of other issues that could cause mood disorders, whether it be anxiety or depression,
or OCD, or inability to handle stress, so we want to take a deeper dive into that,
because that could be a very serious problem, so we want to feel it.